This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When psychologist Robert Chaldeenie was in college, a magazine salesman knocked on his dorm room door. He was selling subscriptions to Sports Illustrated magazine. Bob was going to say no, but then the salesman said, it's the most popular subscription here in your dorm. And the experts rated as the number one sports magazine in the United States. And I found myself buying that subscription. The exchange with the sports illustrated salesman, God Bob Thinking, what exactly had the man said to overcome his resistance?
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当心理学家罗伯特·查尔迪尼还在上大学时，一名杂志推销员敲响了他宿舍的门。他在推销《体育画报》杂志的订阅。鲍勃本来想拒绝，但推销员接着说，这是你们宿舍最受欢迎的订阅刊物。专家将其评为美国第一大体育杂志。然后我发现自己买下了那个订阅。与《体育画报》推销员的交流让鲍勃开始思考，这个人到底说了什么来克服他的抵触情绪？
And could studying exchanges like this reveal why some people were more persuasive than others? But I don't know I had the terms to explain it, but I knew that they had worked and I knew that he had turned a note to a yes. So there was something powerful there inside what he had said. Over the course of several decades of observation and experimental research at Arizona State University, Bob eventually identified seven techniques of influence. Last week on the show, we explored three of them. We looked at the role of scarcity, the norm of reciprocity, and the effects of liking.
研究这样的交流能否揭示为什么有些人比其他人更有说服力？虽然我不知道我当时是否有词汇来解释它，但我知道它们起作用了，我也知道他把一个“不”字变成了一个“是”。所以在他所说的话里面有着某种强大的力量。在亚利桑那州立大学进行了几十年的观察和实验研究之后，鲍勃最终确定了七种影响力技巧。上周的节目中，我们探讨了其中三种。我们研究了稀缺性的作用、互惠规范以及喜好的影响。
If you missed that episode, I would strongly recommend you go back and listen to it first. Today, we explore four more powerful ways to turn nose into yeses. And as we did last week, we will also examine how these ideas can be used for good and for evil. The patterns of persuasion this week on Hidden Brain. Researchers who study disasters have often noticed a curious pattern.
如果你错过了那一集，我强烈建议你回过头去先听那一集。今天，我们将探讨另外四种将“不”变成“是”的强大方法。正如我们上周所做的那样，我们还将探讨这些理念如何被用于好事和坏事。本周的“Hidden Brain”将探讨说服的模式。研究灾害的研究人员经常注意到一种奇怪的模式。
People confronting emergencies often behave like the people around them. In my book The Hidden Brain, I described how these patterns shaped decisions involving life and death on the upper floors of the World Trade Center on September 11, 2001. Shortly after planes hijacked by terrorists struck the skyscrapers, people inside the buildings had to make a choice. Should they run for the stairs and try and climb down dozens of flights to safety, or should they shelter in place? In the confusion and panic that ensued in the moments after the attacks, they received
面对紧急情况的人们的行为往往像他们周围的人一样。在我的书《隐藏的大脑》中，我描述了这些模式如何在2001年9月11日世贸中心高层塑造了生死攸关的决策。在恐怖分子劫持的飞机撞击摩天大楼后不久，大楼里的人们必须做出选择。他们是应该跑向楼梯，试图爬下几十层楼到达安全地带，还是应该原地避难？在袭击发生后随之而来的混乱和恐慌中，他们收到了
conflicting guidance from authorities. But at one company that was spread over two floors of the World Trade Center, I found that people made radically different decisions. Nearly everyone on one floor chose to evacuate, and nearly all survived. Nearly everyone on the other floor stayed in place, and large numbers perished when the tower collapsed. It's not quite right to say that people are sheep and follow the herd. That's unfair and simplistic. But it is the case that one of the most important sources of influence in our lives comes from the people around us. If you are on a floor where everyone is running for the stairs,
来自当局的相互矛盾的指导。但在世贸中心占据了两层楼的一家公司，我发现人们做出了截然不同的决定。其中一层楼的几乎所有人都选择疏散，几乎全部幸存。而另一层楼的几乎所有人都留在了原地，当大楼倒塌时，大量人员丧生。说人们是绵羊并且盲目跟风并不完全准确。这既不公平又过于简单化。但事实确实是，我们生活中最重要的影响力来源之一来自于我们周围的人。如果你身处一层每个人都在跑向楼梯的楼层，
it's hard not to run yourself. If you are on a floor where everyone is running for the stairs, it's hard not to run yourself. If you are on a floor where everyone is staying put, it's hard to jump up and take off. Psychologist Bob Chaldeenie says the same principle known as social proof also works in situations with much lower stakes. Social proof reduces uncertainty in others when we show them that a lot of other people like them are doing or have been doing what we're asking this particular individual to do. We give them confirmation that this is widely accepted, widely performed. And I remember that magazine salesman who came to my dorm room and told me that the sports illustrated subscription
你很难不跟着跑。如果你身处一层每个人都在跑向楼梯的楼层，你很难不跟着跑。如果你身处一层每个人都在原地留守的楼层，你很难跳起来并离开。心理学家鲍勃·查尔迪尼表示，被称为社会认同的同一原则在赌注低得多的情况下也同样适用。当我们向其他人表明，许多和他们一样的人正在做、或者一直在做我们要求这个特定个人去做的事情时，社会认同就会减少他们的不确定性。我们向他们确认这是被广泛接受的、被广泛执行的。我记得那个来到我宿舍的杂志推销员，他告诉我《体育画报》的订阅
was the most popular one of the guys in my dorm. He was using the principle of social proof. And the idea here is that if I have the sense that people in my community, my group, my tribe are basically all doing something, it a becomes easier for me to want to do it, but it also presumably becomes harder for me not to do it, to feel like I'm actually not a member of that group. That's right, and there are three reasons. One is if everybody around me like like me, is doing it,
是我宿舍里某个家伙最喜欢的刊物。他当时正在运用社会认同的原则。这里的理念是，如果我有这样一种感觉，即我社区里的、我的群体里的、我的部落里的人基本上都在做某件事，这不仅让我更想去做它，而且推测起来，这也让我更难不去这样做，更难让我感觉自己其实不是那个群体的一员。没错，这有三个原因。第一，如果我周围每个像我一样的人都在这样做，
that it's probably the right thing to do. It's also probably the case that it's feasible for me to do. And finally, they're more likely to approve of me if I do the things that they are doing instead of being a violator of the norm. So for all those reasons, I'm driven to reduce my uncertainty about what I should do here by following the dictates of social proof. You can see countless examples of the power of social proof in daily life. The same principle is at work when you pass a collection plate at church or when volunteers from the Salvation Army ring a bell outside stores asking for donations. It helps to see that others have previously dropped money on
那么这很可能是正确的事情。这也很有可能是对我而言可行的做法。最后，如果我做他们正在做的事情，而不是做一个违反规范的人，他们更有可能会赞同我。因此，出于所有这些原因，我受到驱使，通过遵循社会认同的指令来减少我对于在这里应该做什么的不确定性。你可以在日常生活中看到无数社会认同力量的例子。当你去教堂时经过奉献盘，或者当救世军的志愿者在商店外面摇铃呼吁捐款时，同样的原则就在起作用。看到其他人之前已经将钱投入
the collection plate or into a collection box. Even if we approve of the person ringing the bell asking us to contribute to some cause at round Christmas time, we can approve of it, but if we don't see other people doing it, it's not necessarily something that is likely to spur us to do it. I mean, I've seen instances of street musicians, Bob, who are playing for money, they'll drop some dollar bills of their own into an open guitar case to send a signal to passers-by that they should make a contribution of their own. Right. There was a lovely study done by a researcher who went door to door for charity and gave
奉献盘或捐款箱里会有所帮助。即使我们赞同摇铃的人呼吁我们在圣诞节前后为某种事业捐款，我们可能会赞同它，但如果我们没有看到其他人在这样做，这不一定是一件能促使我们去做的事情。我的意思是，我见过街头艺人的例子，鲍勃，他们在为钱演奏，他们会把一些自己的纸币投进打开的吉他盒里，向路人发出信号，表明他们应该自己也做出贡献。没错。有个研究人员做过一项很好的研究挨家挨户为慈善事业募捐，并给
people a list of how many of their neighbors had already given and showed them a list. The longer the list, the more likely that the resident was likely to contribute. And the larger the amount of money that each person had given in the neighborhood. The larger that the recipient of that information was to give. I understand there was a wonderful study conducted at a Beijing restaurant where a manager was trying to increase the likelihood of customers choosing particular items from the menu. Tell me about what happened at that restaurant. The researchers had the managers put little asterisks next to certain items on the menu and see what effect that would have.
人们看了一份有多少邻居已经捐过款的名单，并向他们展示了这份名单。名单越长，居民越有可能捐款。而且社区中每个人捐出的金额越大。信息接收者捐款的数额也越大。我听说在北京的一家餐馆进行了一项出色的研究，当时经理正试图增加顾客从菜单中选择特定菜品的可能性。跟我讲讲那家餐馆发生了什么。研究人员让经理们在菜单上的某些菜品旁边加上小星号，看看这会产生什么影响。
What did the asterisk stand for? It didn't say this is a specialty of the house, which you often see. It didn't say this is our chef's selection for this evening. It said this is one of our most popular items. And purchase of those items increased by 13 to 20%. There's this lovely study that was done in McDonald's, in which researchers arranged for the person behind the counter after customers had finished their order to say, and would you like a dessert versus, and would you like a dessert? The McFlurry is our customer's favorite. Those customers who heard the latter bought 45% more desserts because they were informed
星号代表什么？它没有说这是本店特色菜，你经常能看到这种说法。它没有说这是我们今晚的主厨精选。它说这是我们最受欢迎的菜品之一。这些菜品的购买量增加了13%到20%。麦当劳做过一项非常棒的研究，研究人员安排柜台后的员工在顾客点完餐后说：“您要不要来份甜筒，对比一下，您要不要来份甜筒？麦旋风是我们顾客的最爱。”听到后一种说法的顾客多买 了45%的甜筒，因为他们被告知了
about what the most popular one was. They all bought McFlurry's because it was the most popular. One of my favorite examples of social proof that you described has to do with how your son learned to swim. Tell me that story, Bob. So my son, Chris, when he was about three years old, we live in Arizona, and I worry that because there are so many backyard swimming pools, he might fall in. And if he didn't know how to swim, that would be very unfortunate.
哪一款是最受欢迎的。他们都买了麦旋风，因为它最受欢迎。你描述的社会认同的最爱例子之一与你儿子如何学会游泳有关。讲讲那个故事吧，鲍勃。所以我的儿子克里斯，当他大约三岁的时候，我们住在亚利桑那州，我担心因为有太多的后院游泳池，他可能会掉进去。如果他不会游泳，那将是非常不幸的。
So I put him in a swimming class and didn't work. I even hired one of my research assistants who had been a lifeguard, big six foot two guy who was a very expert at swim. Chris wouldn't even get in the pool with this guy without his ring. You know, this plastic ring that he would wear. He loved the water, but only with that ring, he wouldn't go in without it. And then I had him in a day camp,
所以我把他送去游泳班，但没有起作用。我甚至雇用了我的一位研究助理，他曾是一名救生员，一个身高六尺二寸、非常精通游泳的大个子。克里斯甚至不肯戴着他的泳圈跟这个人一起下水。你知道的，他会戴的那种塑料泳圈。他喜欢水，但只能戴着那个泳圈，没有它他就不肯进去。后来我把他送进了一个日间营地，
where there was a big swimming pool. Usually he didn't go near it, but I went to pick him up one day, and I saw him run down the diving board and jump into the middle of the pool without his ring on and he paddled over to the side I ran there I said Chris you're swimming and he said yes because Jimmy can swim and Jimmy's three years old like me that means I can swim. like me. That means I can swim. So that's the idea again here it's about feasibility. It's not necessarily that swimming is the right thing or the approving. It's feasible.
那里有一个大游泳池。通常他不会靠近它，但有一天我去接他，我看到他跑下跳板，没戴泳圈就跳进了泳池中间，然后划水游到了岸边。我跑过去说：“克里斯，你在游泳！”他说：“是的，因为吉米会游泳，而且吉米和我一样三岁，这意味着我也能游泳。”像我一样。这意味着我也能游泳。所以这里的核心理念再次关于可行性。不一定是因为游泳是正确的事情或是受到赞许的。而是它是可行的。
If the people around me like me are able to do this. You know, I'm thinking of that wonderful story for many decades ago where John Lundy and Roger Banister were trying to break the four-minute mile, and Lundy was an Australian runner and one of the best runners on the planet and widely considered to be the person most likely to break the four-minute mile, and he ran several races and got very, very, very close and was just unable to break through the barrier. And at one point he says, you know, I don't believe this barrier is so roundtable. I don't believe humans can run a mile in less than four minutes. And then Roger Bannister, of course, famously went on to break the barrier.
如果周围像我一样的人能够做到这一点。你知道的，我想起了几十年前那个精彩的故事，当时约翰·兰迪和罗杰·班尼斯塔正试图打破四分钟跑完一英里的纪录，兰迪是一位澳大利亚跑步运动员，也是地球上最好的跑步运动员之一，被广泛认为是最有可能打破四分钟一英里纪录的人，他参加了几场比赛，跑得非常、非常、非常接近，但就是无法突破这个障壁。在某个时刻他说：“你知道的，我不相信这个障壁是无法打破的。我不相信人类能在一分钟内……”抱歉，“我不相信人类能以小于四分钟的时间跑完一英里。”然后罗杰·班尼斯塔当然一举打破了这个纪录，
He ran a four-minute mile. But what's astonishing about the story is that the very next race, John Landy ran a mile in under four minutes. And what's astonishing there is that this is one of the best runners in the world has tried repeatedly, repeatedly, repeatedly, and unable to break the barrier. Someone else does it, and it suddenly becomes possible. And I think it speaks to this idea
他跑出了四分钟以内的一英里。但这个故事令人惊讶的地方在于，就在下一场比赛中，约翰·兰迪也在四分钟以内跑完了一英里。令人惊讶的是，这是世界上最好的跑步运动员之一，他尝试了一次又一次、一次又一次，却无法打破这个障壁。当别人做到了，它突然变得可行了。我认为这说明了这样一个观点，
that you just talked about Bob, which is that one really important element of social proof is that it communicates to us that this is actually feasible. It's actually within the realm of possibility. Right. We have done some work with informing the owners about why they should reduce their energy consumption. And if we give them evidence that their neighbors are reducing, they get significantly more likely to, indeed, conserve more.
你刚才谈到的，鲍勃，也就是社会认同的一个非常重要的元素是，它向我们传达了这实际上是可行的。这实际上在可能性的范畴之内。没错。我们做过一些工作，告知业主他们为什么要减少能源消耗。如果我们向他们提供证据表明他们的邻居正在减少消耗，他们确实更有可能去节约更多能源。
Because it's feasible, we don't just give them evidence of any neighbors, we give them evidence of comparable neighbors, those who have the same, home, the same type of air conditioning, units, and the same number of bedrooms and so on, and if those things are in place and they can do it, that means I can do it. Social proof can be used for good, but it can also be used for evil. One of the oldest tricks of fraudsters and con men is to show people that other people who are just like them have signed on to some scheme. Once financier Bernie Madoff showed his victims that other people were giving him money and
因为这是可行的，我们不仅向他们提供任何邻居的证据，我们提供可比邻居的证据，那些拥有相同房屋、相同类型的空调机组、相同卧室数量等等的邻居，如果这些条件都具备并且他们能做到，那就意味着我也能做到。社会认同可以被用于好事，但它也可以被用于坏事。诈骗犯和骗子最古老的伎俩之一就是向人们展示其他和他们完全一样的人已经加入了某个计划。一旦金融家伯尼·麦道夫向他的受害者展示其他人正在给他钱，并且
he was giving them astronomical returns, he didn't have to market his scam to new victims. The marks came to him, begging him to take their money. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Bob Chaldeeni has always thought of himself as easy to persuade. From a young age, he found himself saying yes to salespeople and pictures for charity. In time, Bob decided he wanted to understand the psychology of influence. He started out his research by infiltrating a number of groups where people made money by persuading others to say yes to them.
他正给他们提供天文数字般的回报，他就不必向新的受害者营销他的骗局了。受害者们主动来找他，乞求他收下他们的钱。您正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维达塔。这里是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维达塔姆。心理学家鲍勃·查尔迪尼一直认为自己很容易被说服。从小时候起，他就发现自己会对推销员和慈善募捐请求说“好”。随着时间推移，鲍勃决定他想了解影响力的心理学。他的研究始于潜入一些群体，这些人通过说服别人对他们说“好”来赚钱。
He spent time selling cars, hawking portrait photos, and fundraising. Over several decades of research at Arizona State University, Bob has identified seven techniques of persuasion that nearly every human being is susceptible to. In this episode, we've talked about the power of social proof. A related idea unfolds in nearly every workplace, family and community. Some people in these groups have a very obvious and powerful form of influence. They have authority. It plays a role that's not unlike social proof in that it reduces uncertainty as to what to do based on the information at hand.
他花时间卖过汽车、兜售过肖像照片并进行过筹款。在亚利桑那州立大学进行了几十年的研究后，鲍勃确定了几乎每个人都容易受其影响的七种说服技巧。在本集中，我们讨论了社会认同的力量。一个相关的理念几乎在每一个职场、家庭和社区中展开。这些群体中的某些人拥有非常明显且强大的影响力形式。他们拥有权威。它发挥的作用与社会认同非常相似，因为它根据手头的信息减少了该做什么的不确定性。
If I see that a lot of my friends or colleagues, neighbors are doing something that reduces my uncertainty that I should do. And if I see evidence of authority voices speaking about a particular direction for me to take, it reduces my uncertainty that indeed this is probably the right thing to do. The magazine salesman who was trying to sell you sports illustrator didn't just tell you that it was the most popular magazine. He also said it was the highest rated sports magazine. And of course, I think all manner of sales people do this are basically saying this is the best television. This is the best kind of car. This is the highest rated product. This is the best university ratings effectively are the voice of authority speaking to us. Well, especially if those ratings are coming from
如果我看到我的很多朋友、同事、邻居在做某件事，这就减少了我应该去做的不确定性。如果我看到权威声音谈论我应该采取特定方向的证据，这就减少了我对于这确实可能是正确事情的不确定性。那个试图向你推销《体育画报》的杂志推销员不仅告诉你这是最受欢迎的杂志。他还说这是评分最高的体育杂志。当然，我认为各种各样的推销员都在这样做，他们基本上是在说这是最好的电视。这是最好的汽车。这是最高评分的产品。最好的大学评分实际上是对我们说话的权威之声。
knowledgeable experts in the field, which this salesperson told me, didn't just say it was the highest rated by consumers, that would have been more of social proof. He said, and it was the highest rated by the experts in the field of sports as to which magazine is best at conveying what really goes on in that arena. I remember reading a study recently where they had people essentially walk on the street
嗯，特别是如果这些评分来自该领域的知识渊博的专家，这位推销员告诉我，不仅说它是消费者评级最高的，如果那样的话，这更偏向于社会认同。他说，这是体育领域的专家评选出的最擅长传达该领域真实情况的杂志。我记得最近读过一项研究，他们让人们基本上在街上
and bark instructions at passers-by, you know, just sort of random instructions saying, you know, this parking meter seems to be empty. Why don't you put a dime in it, just sort of telling a stranger. And when the instructions were given by somebody wearing a uniform, compliance with those instructions basically went through the roof. So even if you don't know who the authority figure is, what the uniform represents, the mere fact that someone's wearing a uniform
向路人发出指令，你知道的，就只是一些随意的指令，说：“这个停车计时器好像空了。你为什么不投进一个十分硬币呢？”就只是对陌生人这样说。当这些指令由一个穿着制服的人发出时，对这些指令的顺从度基本上直线上升。因此，即使你不知道权威人物是谁，制服代表什么，有人穿着制服这一纯粹的事实
indicates this must be a person of authority. Right. This was a security guard's uniform. It wasn't a police officer, a security guard. But somebody had the aura of authority. The one I loved best was where he told people, you're standing at a bus stop and he said, stand on the other side of the bus stop.
就表明这一定是一个权威人物。没错。这是一个保安的制服。不是警察，是一名保安。但某人拥有权威的气场。我最喜欢的一个例子是，他告诉人们，你站在一个公交车站，他说：“站在公交车站的另一边。”
Go to the other side and stand there and people did. And then he left the scene, he turned the corner and he was gone and people still stayed and had on the other side of the bus stop because the authority figure had instructed them to do so. Yeah. And it is partly the case, of course, that people are deferred to authority, but as you say, it also is cognitively simpler to do it. To basically say someone who is in charge has figured out what we should do, they have thought through what the answer should be. I don't have to expand the time and energy thinking about it. Precisely right. I think that that's the shortcut.
去另一边站着，人们照做了。然后他离开了现场，拐过弯走了，而人们依然留在那里，站在公交车站的另一边，因为权威人物指示他们这么做。是的。当然，部分原因确实是人们顺从权威，但正如你所说，这样做在认知上也更简单。基本上就是说，负责的人已经弄清楚了我们应该做什么，他们已经思考过答案应该是什么。我不必花费时间和精力去思考它。完全正确。我认为这就是捷径。
Hmm. I don't need to do the testing now. Somebody else with greater knowledge and experience and expertise has done so. I can usually be right if I just follow. I can usually be right if I just follow. This is why electing the right leaders is so important. A president is not just someone who signs bills into laws. If a president tells us we have nothing to fear but fear itself, we feel braver. If a president tells us that a vaccine is suspect, that makes us hesitate to put our arms out for a jab. This also explains why dictators are
嗯。我现在不需要做测试。其他人拥有更渊博的知识、经验和专业技能，他们已经做过了。如果我只是跟随，通常就能保持正确。如果我只是跟随，通常就能保持正确。这就是为什么选出正确的领导者如此重要。总统不仅仅是一个把法案签署成法律的人。如果总统告诉我们，除了恐惧本身，我们没有什么好怕的，我们就会感到勇敢。如果总统告诉我们，某种疫苗是不可信的，这就会让我们犹豫是否要伸出胳膊去接种。这也解释了为什么独裁者能够
able to muster so much power. Yes, some of this power flows from guns and weapons, but a great deal of it is psychological. In the face of authority, dissenters often hide their views or withdraw from argument. Bob once had this experience himself, although in a context when no one was holding a gun to his head. I was sitting next to an Oxford Don, whose research area was Italian culture and Italian productivity, and I was making a comment about compared to the past when the sculpture and paintings and so on that came out of Italy were the best and they had stood the test of time that now it seemed to be more something ephemeral that it was fashioned and fooled and
聚敛如此巨大的权力。是的，这种权力的部分来源是枪支和武器，但很大程度上是心理上的。面对权威，持不同政见者往往会隐藏自己的观点或退出争论。鲍勃自己也曾有过这样的经历，尽管当时并没有人拿枪指着他的头。我当时正坐在一个牛津大学学者旁边，他的研究领域是意大利文化和意大利生产力，我当时在发表评论说，与过去相比，过去意大利产出的雕塑、绘画等等是最好的，并且经受住了时间的考验，而现在它似乎更像是一种转瞬即逝的东西，它是被塑造、愚弄出来的
these kinds of things a style. And he said to me, I must degrade your thesis. I'm a guy who was always competitive in an intellectual. He completely eliminated and he come back I would have because he was an author. He came off with authority related language and it made me recognize that he knew more than I did about this. And I should shut my mouth because I really didn't have the high ground here. You talk about another form of influence that has to do with commitment and consistency, which is that we want to feel like we are being consistent in the way we act. Talk about this idea, Bob.
以及诸如此类的风格。然后他对我说，我必须贬低你的论点。我是一个在知识上总是好胜的人。他完全驳倒了我，并进行了反击，因为他是一个学者。他用了带有权威色彩的语言，这让我意识到他在这个领域的了解比我多。我应该闭上嘴巴，因为我在这里确实没有占到上风。你谈到了另一种与承诺和一致性有关的影响形式，那就是我们希望在自己的行为方式上感到一致。谈谈这个想法，鲍勃。
How does this work? Well, one of the things that people prefer is to be seen as consistent so that they're not incongruent in terms of what they say and what they do, or they say one thing today, they say another thing the other day. We don't like those individuals. We don't like people who are all over the world. We can predict or count on. So one of the things that commitment and consistency does if if we make a commitment especially in public, we're significantly more likely to be congruent with it if we are asked to do so at a later stage in the interaction. There was a Chicago restaurant that was once having a problem with people not showing up
这是如何起作用的呢？嗯，人们更喜欢的一点是被人视为具有一致性，这样他们在言行上就不会自相矛盾，或者今天说一套，明天又说另一套。我们不喜欢这样的人。我们不喜欢那些立场摇摆不定、无法预测或信赖的人。因此，承诺和一致性所做的事情之一就是——如果我们做出承诺，特别是在公众面前做出承诺，如果在互动后期的某个阶段被要求这样做，我们就更有可能与之保持一致。曾经有一家芝加哥餐馆遇到过这样一个问题：人们没有按时出现
at the time of their reservation. Tell me what they did to try and increase compliance with when people said they were going to show up and actually showed up. Yeah, it was a police called Gordon's restaurant. And Gordon, he had a problem that was at the time not unique to his restaurant, no shows. People who called, booked a table, and then just didn't appear, didn't call ahead to cancel. And it was a big problem for him. And he went to listen to what his receptionist said when she took a reservation. She would say, thank you for calling Gordon's
在预约的时间。告诉我他们为了提高人们承诺出现并实际出现的遵守率做了什么。是的，那是一家叫戈登的餐馆。戈登遇到了一个当时在他的餐馆并不罕见的问题，即爽约。人们打电话预订了桌位，然后却没有出现，也没有提前打电话取消。这对他来说是个大问题。他去听了听他的前台接待员在接听预订电话时是怎么说的。她会说，谢谢您致电戈登餐馆。
restaurant. Please call if you have to change or cancel your reservation. That ended the call. He asked her to add two words and to say, will you please call if you have to change your cancel your reservation? And then he asked her to pause. So what would you say? How would you fill that pause? I would say yes, of course I would call. And that's your commitment, Sean. You have now publicly committed yourself to it, and no shows at Gordon's restaurant dropped
如果您需要更改或取消预订，请打电话给我们。通话就这样结束了。他请她加上两个词，说：如果您需要更改或取消预订，您会打电话给我们吗？然后他请她停顿一下。那么你会说什么？你会如何填补这段停顿？我会说，是的，我当然会打电话。这就是你的承诺，尚克。你现在已经公开做出了承诺，戈登餐馆的爽约率下降了
by 64% that they never went back up. And do you think that this is being shaped by a desire for image management, that I care what the receptionist at the restaurant thinks, and I don't want her to think less of me, or do you think it's primarily about how I think of myself. I have made a commitment to the restaurant to show up on time, and so I need to call if I'm actually going to cancel. It is both of those things. You want to see yourself as a person who lives up to his or her commitments. And it's in private that you make
64%，而且再也没有回升。你认为这是由形象管理的愿望塑造的吗？因为我在乎餐馆接待员对我的看法，我不想让她看轻我，还是你认为这主要关乎我自己如何看待自己？我对餐馆做出了按时出现的承诺，所以如果我要取消，我需要打电话。这两种情况都有。你想把自己看作一个兑现承诺的人。而私下里做出的承诺
a commitment. You get a significant increase. But if it's in public, you get a much larger increase in congruency of a subsequent behavior. The one that produces the biggest leap forward in terms of compliance, it's the public commitment. One of the techniques that follows from this principle is something called the foot in the door technique. What is the foot in the door technique? It's a technique that was technique. What is the foot in the door technique? It's a technique that was uncovered back in the 60s by Jonathan Friedman, in which he asked people to make a small initial step in a particular direction. And after they had done so, ask them to behave in a way that was consistent with that step.
你会得到显著的增长。但如果是在公共场合，你在随后的行为一致性上会得到更大的提升。在提高遵守率方面带来最大飞跃的是公开承诺。源于这一原则的技术之一就是所谓的“登门槛”技术。什么是“登门槛”技术？这是一项——是一项技术。什么是“登门槛”技术？这是一项在60年代被乔纳森·弗里德曼发明的技术，他要求人们在某个特定方向上迈出很小的一步。在他们这样做之后，要求他们做出与那一步相一致的行为。
Later, the interesting thing is that if they had made that first step, they were significantly more likely to say yes to the larger request than if they hadn't been asked to make the small step first. So the classic study was people in Palo Alto, California, Friedman was at Stanford at the time. They were asked to take a small, to put a small sign in their window of their car or their home that said, please drive safely, national driver safety. Some were asked to do so. Others of their neighbors were not asked to do that. Then a week later, somebody came to their homes and asked them to put a big sign on their lawn promoting driver safety week. Those people who put the
后来，有趣的是，如果他们迈出了第一步，他们答应更大请求的可能性要显著高于如果没有被要求先迈出小步的情况。所以经典的实验是关于加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托市的人们的，弗里德曼当时在斯坦福大学。他们被要求在他们的汽车或家庭窗户上贴一个标志，上面写着“请安全驾驶，国家驾驶安全”。一些人被要求这样做。他们的其他邻居则没有被要求这样做。然后在一周后，有人来到他们的家里，要求他们在草坪上竖起一个大的标志，宣传驾驶安全周。那些在窗户上贴了
small sign on in their window were significantly more likely to put the large sign on their lawn because it was congruent with what they had already committed themselves. I mean, isn't it interesting? If I ask you for a small favor and you say yes to me and I come back to you and I'm asking you for a big favor, I've actually asked you for two favors now, but you become more likely to say yes to the second favor and the first favor if you said yes to the first favor, then if I only asked you about the second favor, that's kind of astonishing. It is astonishing, but the key is that the second favor has to be logically congruent with the first one. So you see yourself as being consistent now, which is a powerful motive. Because of course, if you say no to the second, then it asks you to ask yourself the question,
小标志的人更有可能在草坪上竖起大标志，因为这与他们已经做出的承诺相一致。我的意思是，这难道不有趣吗？如果我向你寻求一个小帮助，你答应了，然后我回来向你寻求一个大帮助，我实际上已经向你寻求了两次帮助，但如果你对第一个帮助说“好”，那么你对第二个帮助说“好”的可能性就会增加，甚至比我只向你询问第二个帮助时更大，这有点令人震惊。确实令人震惊，但关键在于，第二个帮助必须在逻辑上与第一个保持一致。所以你现在把自己看作是一个前后一致的人，这是一个强大的动机。因为当然，如果你对第二个请求说“不”，那么它就会让你问自己这样一个问题，
well, why did I put that sign up on my window in the first place? Do I not really believe in it? Am I a hypocrite? Do I not really care about driver safety? All these questions start to pop in your head. And we want to be consistent. We want to have views of ourselves as having coherent choices, positions, attitudes, and so on. You have a friend Bob who has been especially successful in job interviews. What does your friend do when he sits down in a job interview? This is an individual who had been relatively unsuccessful before in getting successful job interviews, and he decided to do a small thing that changed the profile of his successes.
嗯，我当初为什么要在我窗户上贴那个标志？难道我真的不相信它吗？我是个伪君子吗？我真的不关心驾驶安全吗？所有这些问题开始在你的脑海中浮现。我们希望保持一致。我们希望将自己视为做出连贯选择、立场、态度等的人。鲍勃，你有一个在求职面试中特别成功的朋友。你的朋友在求职面试中坐下时会做什么？这是一个以前在成功获得工作面试机会方面相对不成功的人，他决定做一件小事，从而改变了他成功的面貌。
Usually what he would do at the beginning of an interview with one person or sometimes it's two or three individuals who are evaluating. He would say, I'm very happy that you had me come in and I want to answer all of your questions. And then he would add, but I'm curious about something. I wonder if you could answer a question for me. Why did you invite me here? What was it about my resume, about my qualifications, about my background that caused you to invite me? And he would hear them make commitments to his traits and values and fit. And then they would continue to be consistent with those positive comments they made, and he said he's gotten three better jobs in a role by using this commitment and consistency strategy.
通常他在面试开始时会这样做，面试对象是一个人，有时是两三个评估人员。他会说，我很高兴您邀请我来，我想回答您的所有问题。然后他会补充说，但我对一件事很好奇。我想知道您是否能回答我一个问题？您为什么邀请我来？我的简历、资格或背景中有什么吸引您邀请我的地方？然后他会听到他们对他的特质、价值观和契合度做出承诺。然后他们会继续与他们所做的那些积极评价保持一致，他说通过使用这种承诺和一致性的策略，他已经连续得到了三份更好的工作。
When Bob first published his book about influence in 1984, he stopped there. He said he had found six main techniques of influence, scarcity, reciprocity, liking, social proof, authority, and commitment and consistency. But as time went on, he noticed one more. You can see this form of influence come election time. It's something Bob calls the principle of unity. I started to see the literature in behavioral science on the effects of belonging to a particular social identity category that would cause people to feel very positively toward those to whom they could use the word we, who are we in its religious denominations, political parties, neighborhoods,
当鲍勃在1984年首次出版关于影响力的书时，他到此为止了。他说他发现了影响力的六大主要技术：稀缺性、互惠性、喜好、社会认同、权威以及承诺和一致性。但随着时间的推移，他注意到了又一个。你可以在选举时看到这种形式的影响力。这就是鲍勃所说的统一原则。我开始在行为科学文献中看到关于属于特定社会认同类别的影响的研究，这会使人们对那些他们可以使用“我们”这个词的人产生非常积极的感觉，我们是谁，包括宗教教派、政党、社区、
communities, all kinds of we groups exist. We the people. We never bow, we never been, we groups exist. We the people. We never bow. We never been. We never break. We can forever. And above all else, we know this. In America, we go. And if a communicator can convince me that he or she is not just like me, but one of me of us. That lends itself to influence. I am much more likely to be influenced by the suggestions, requests, proposals, recommendations of that sort of person. Very often, that's a way that people use to decide what they should do. What are the people who I am of doing in this situation?
社区，各种“我们”群体都存在。我们人民。我们永不屈服，我们永不退缩，“我们”群体存在。我们人民。我们永不屈服。我们永不退缩。我们永不决裂。我们可以永远。最重要的是，我们知道这一点。在美国，我们前行。如果一个沟通者能说服我，他或她不仅像我，而且是“我们”中的一员。这本身就会产生影响力。我更有可能受到这种人的建议、请求、提议、推荐的影响。通常，这是人们用来决定自己应该做什么的方法。在这种情况下，与我同类的人在做什么？
And why don't make a distinction between simply being like someone and being of or one of that person's group? Certainly, when we're talking about political campaigns, you see this in space, which is that people are essentially making pleas to saying, if you're one of us, this is what you and you would support. If you're one of us, this is how you should vote. If you're one of us, this is the candidate that you should go out and vote for. And both work, but it's the unity principle that I think is the most powerful. One is about identity, shared identity.
为什么不把“仅仅和某人相像”与“属于或作为该人的群体之一”区分开来呢？当然，当我们谈论政治竞选时，你在空间中会看到这一点，人们本质上是在呼吁：如果你是我们的自己人，这就是你将支持的。如果你是我们的自己人，这就是你应该投票的方式。如果你是我们的自己人，这就是你应该出去投票支持的候选人。这两种方式都管用，但我认为统一原则是最强大的。一个是关于身份的，即共享身份。
It's something in which you feel that you share a wee category with those individuals. That's very powerful. We favor and we follow those individuals with whom we share identities, social or personal identities. Recently, Bob discovered an affinity for someone he shares an identity with. The rapper Lil Wayne. I grew up in Wisconsin, the National Football League and a team in Wisconsin, that I had always favored, was the Green Bay Packers, still is the Green Bay Packers, and I saw an article in the newspaper a few months ago that said what the famous celebrities were for each of the teams that supported each of the teams. And Justin Timberlake and Lil Wayne were avid Green Bay Packer fans, like me.
这是某种让你觉得你与这些人共享一个“我们”类别的事情。这非常强大。我们偏爱并追随那些与我们共享身份（社会或个人身份）的人。最近，鲍勃发现他对一个与自己共享身份的人产生了好感。说唱歌手李·韦恩。我在威斯康星州长大，国家美式橄榄球联盟以及威斯康星州的一支球队，我一直偏爱的是绿湾包装工队，现在仍然是绿湾包装工队，几个月前我在报纸上看到一篇文章，上面列出了支持每支球队的名人都是谁。贾斯汀·汀布莱克和李·韦恩是绿湾包装工队的狂热粉丝，就像我一样。
Shanker, I immediately felt better about their music. And this is the key for influence. I wanted them to succeed more than before. After I learned that like me, they were avid, green-bay, packer fans. They shared an identity with me, and it made me favorable to them. What do you think is actually happening here? The fact that the two of you like the same sports teams, the rationalist would say, what does that have to do with whether you like their music or not, but what's the connection?
尚克，我对他们的音乐立刻有了更好的感觉。这就是影响力的关键。在得知他们像我一样是绿湾包装工队的狂热粉丝后，我比以前更希望他们成功。他们与我共享了一个身份，这让我对他们产生了好感。你认为这里实际上发生了什么？你们俩喜欢相同的运动球队这一事实，理性主义者会说，这跟你们是否喜欢他们的音乐有什么关系，但其中的联系是什么？
The connection is that we share a group identity. So, and that's been the way we've evolved, that to favor those who are in our group, because typically, we were genetically related in our small groups, our bands and clans and so on. So, where we find this sense of groupiness, we want to benefit those who share our genetic makeup. I understand that you were once completing a grant application with a very short deadline
联系在于我们共享一个群体身份。所以，这也是我们进化的方式，即偏爱我们群体中的人，因为通常情况下，在我们的群落、部落和氏族等小型群体中，我们是有基因亲缘关系的。因此，在我们发现这种群体感的地方，我们想要造福那些与我们共享基因构成的人。我听说你曾经在截止日期非常紧迫的情况下填写一份资助申请，
and you were trying to get the help of a colleague and that help was not forthcoming and you decided to use one of your own techniques to try and elicit some of that help. Tell me the story, what happened, Bob? So I was writing a grant proposal, it was due the next day, I was reviewing it. One last time, and I came to one section, and I realized, I really didn't have the evidence to support my contentions in that place.
你试图获得一位同事的帮助，但没有得到帮助，于是你决定使用你自己的技术之一来试图引出一些帮助。给我讲讲这个故事，发生了什么，鲍勃？当时我正在写一份资助申请，第二天就要截止了，我正在复审它。最后一次复审时，我来到了一个部分，我意识到，我真的没有证据来支持我那里的论点。
What I had a colleague, let's call him Tim, wasn't his name, who had done a study the year before and had collected evidence that was indeed supportive. And I thought, well, I'm going to write to Tim and tell him the situation that I have this grant proposal. Let's do the next day. There's a weakness. You have some data in your archives. I'm going to phone you and see if we can arrange for you to get those data, send them to me so I can get into my proposal before the deadline. Now Tim was known to be a sour kind of a rassable guy, not a guy who's very agreeable or likeable. I called him and he said, Bob, I know why you're calling and the answer is no.
我有一位同事，我们叫他蒂姆，虽然这不是他的真名，他在前一年做过一项研究，并收集了确实能提供支持的证据。我想，好吧，我要写信给蒂姆，告诉他我的情况，我有一份资助申请。明天就要截止了。有一个弱点。你的档案里有一些数据。我要给你打电话，看看我们能否安排你获取这些数据，并把它们发给我，以便我在截止日期前把它写进我的提案里。现在蒂姆以脾气古怪、不好相处而闻名，不是一个非常随和或讨人喜欢的人。我给他打电话，他说，鲍勃，我知道你为什么打电话，答案是“不”。
The answer is no. Look, you're a busy man. You have a deadline. I'm a busy man. I have deadlines. I can't help you with your poor time management skills, Bob. Before I saw all this research on group identity and unity, I would have said, come on, Tim. This is due tomorrow. I really need this. Well, he had already said,
答案是“不”。听着，你是个大忙人。你有一个截止日期。我是个大忙人。我有截止日期。我无法帮助你解决糟糕的时间管理技巧问题，鲍勃。在我看到所有关于群体认同和统一的研究之前，我会说，拜托，蒂姆。这个明天就要交了。我真的很需要这个。好吧，他已经说过
note of that. So I said, come on Tim, I really need this. We've been members of the same psychology department now for 12 years. And shocker, I had the data that afternoon. I raised our collective identity to consciousness here. This is what we do for one another. to consciousness here. This is what we do for one another. When we come back, how these powerful techniques of influence can be used for good and for evil. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
不。所以我说，拜托，蒂姆，我真的很需要这个。我们现在做同一个心理学系的同事已经12年了。尚克，那天下午我就拿到了数据。我在这里唤醒了我们的集体认同意识。这就是我们为彼此所做的事情。这就是我们为彼此所做的事情。当我们回来时，将探讨这些强大的影响力技术如何被用于善恶两途。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚克·维丹塔姆。
In his book, Influence Bob Chaldeeni writes about the psychology of persuasion. He describes seven techniques that we can use to influence those around us. These tools can be applied in many areas of life and they can be used for good ends and for bad ones. Social proof, for example, can be used to help people cut back on energy consumption. Well, the way in which I think it can be used
鲍勃·查尔迪尼在他的著作《影响力》中写到了说服的心理学。他描述了七种我们可以用来影响周围人的技术。这些工具可以应用于生活的许多领域，它们既可以用于好的目的，也可以用于坏的目的。例如，社会认同可以用来帮助人们减少能源消耗。嗯，我认为它可以在基于政策的环境中发挥作用的方式，与我们同名为O-Power的组织所做的一些工作有关。他们与电力公司合作，我们将关于他们在能源消耗方面相对于邻居处于什么地位的信息发送给他们的客户。在O-Power开业的10年里，这取得了显著的成功。当人们的能源消耗高于标准时，它会促使他们减少能源消耗。自从我们开始这项策略以来，它已经阻止了360亿磅的二氧化碳进入环境。你能想出一种使用社会认同的方法吗？
in a policy-based setting, it has to do with some work that we have done with an organization called O-Power. They work with power companies, and we send to their customers information about where they stand relative to their neighbors in energy consumption. That has been remarkably successful in the 10 years in which all power has been in business. It causes people to reduce their energy consumption when they are above the norm. It has prevented 36 billion pounds of carbon dioxide from entering the environment since we've begun this strategy. Can you think of a way of using social proof in a
这会有问题或是不道德吗？是的，你不是指出它的存在，而是通过用支持你立场的支持率统计数据撒谎来告知人们。那是不道德的。所以另一种是，如果我基本上向人们传达，绝大多数人支持这个提议或那个提议，这本质上是一种操纵人们去支持我希望他们支持的提议的方法，而实际上这背后的真相可能并不准确。完全正确。
way that would be problematic or unethical? Yeah, rather than pointing to its existence, you inform people by lying with statistics of the amount of support for your position. That would be unethical. So another one is if I basically communicate to people, the vast number of people support this proposition or that proposition, it's a way of basically manipulating people into supporting the proposition that I want them to support, when in fact that the underlying truth of that might not be accurate. Exactly.
我们的一位前总统经常被记录到这样说：“很多人这么说。很多人说我赢了，对此我感到非常高兴。听到这个总是很高兴，但你的许多同僚都说我今天赢了。大多数人说我赢了，我想你也这么认为。很多人说他们在我竞选团队里安插了间谍。如果他们在我的竞选团队里安插了间谍。或者很多，我从很多人那里听说过。”
One of our former presidents is often recorded saying, many people say this. A lot of people said I won, and I'm very happy about that. It's always nice to hear that, but many of your cohorts have said I won this today. Most people said I won, and I think you believe that too. A lot of people are saying they had spies in my campaign. If they had spies in my campaign. Or a lot, I've heard from a lot of people
很多
without ever documenting those numbers or the reality of those people, but that's a common approach. It's not just politics. This kind of manipulation happens all the time on social media. Take the example of click farms. From Instagram accounts with thousands of likes and followers to Facebook posts that go viral overnight. off-click farms. following accounts, liking photos, and watching videos, all the drive up fake traffic. The idea here is that more followers equals more popularity. More popularity equals proof that others should also follow them. Social proof drives virality.
从不记录这些数字或那些人的现实，但这是一种常见的方法。这不仅仅是政治。这种操纵在社交媒体上时刻都在发生。以点击工厂为例。从拥有数千个赞和粉丝的Instagram账号，到一夜之间走红的Facebook帖子。脱离点击工厂。关注账号、给照片点赞、观看视频，这一切都在推高虚假的流量。这里的理念是，更多的粉丝等于更高的人气。更高的人气等于向他人证明他们也应该关注自己。社会认同推动了病毒式传播。
You can think of similar positive and negative forms of manipulation using the influence principle of consistency. There's some good research that shows that charity agencies that simply remind people that they have been generous in the past, let's say, with the flood victims of in Bangladesh, you remind them of their history and commitment to pro-social action, then ask them to help the hurricane victims in Miami, and they're more willing to do so, just because you've reminded that you brought to consciousness their commitment to pro-sociality. I'm wondering, you know, when I think about politics, it feels like very often we
你可以利用影响力原则中的一致性原理，联想到类似的正面和负面的操纵形式。有一些很好的研究表明，慈善机构如果只是提醒人们他们过去曾经很慷慨，比如说，对孟加拉国的洪水受灾者，你提醒他们的历史以及对亲社会行为的承诺，然后请求他们帮助迈阿密的飓风受灾者，他们会更愿意这样做，仅仅因为你提醒了他们，唤醒了他们对亲社会性的承诺。我在想，你知道的，当我想到政治时，感觉很多时候我们
castigate politicians when they change their minds on something. When someone says, I believed X, but now I believe Y. Of course, when you think about it, which would you actually prefer? Would you prefer the politician who believes X and never changes his or her mind for the next 30 years? Or would you prefer someone who says, I believe X, but now new information has come in, and I'm going to revise my opinion to Y. And it feels as if the norm of consistency is actually something that we punish people with. And we sort of say, you know, this person is a flip flop or if they change their minds. I'm not sure that sort of necessarily it's a misuse of consistency. No one's actually manipulating us in that sense, but in some ways it's a misapplication of the principle, you know, domain where actually is not providing probably good results.
当政客在某些事情上改变主意时，我们会严厉斥责他们。当某个人说，我曾经相信X，但我现在相信Y。当然，仔细想想，你实际上更喜欢哪一个？你是更喜欢那个相信X并且在接下来的30年里从不改变他或她想法的政客？还是更喜欢那个说，我相信X，但现在有了新信息，我打算将我的意见修正为Y的人？感觉一致性的规范实际上是我们用来惩罚人们的东西。我们有点像在说，你知道的，这个人是个动摇不定的人，或者他们改变了主意。我不确定这是否必然是对一致性的误用。没有人真正在那种意义上操纵我们，但在某些方面，这是对这一原则的误用，它在某些本不该发挥良好作用的领域被应用了。
Right. I like the way you characterize someone who would move as someone who said, well, there's new information that's come into the system. With that, I prefer that politician. Provided I agree that the information is valid, that's the sort of person I want to be making judgments based on the current and valid evidence. But people who say, well, I've changed my mind now. I don't feel that way that I said I did. But they don't tell you why. That's somebody who's just flipping to attract voters. The political sphere is right for efforts to influence and manipulate. Political actors use their authority to get their way.
对。我喜欢你对一个会改变立场的人的描述，那个人会说，好吧，系统里来了新信息。有了这个，我更倾向于那个政客。前提是我同意这些信息是有效的，这就是我希望根据当前且有效的证据来做出判断的那种人。但那些说，好吧，我现在改变主意了。我不再有我以前说的那种感觉了。但他们不告诉你原因。那是那种为了吸引选民而随风倒的人。政治领域充斥着影响和操纵的努力。政治行动者利用他们的权威来达到他们的目的。
They use commitment and consistency to lobby their colleagues. And they use the principle of unity to appeal to potential voters. It's a wee versus they argument that people make. If the other side is saying it, then we don't want to do it. If our side is taking this position, it really almost doesn't matter what the merits of it is. It's one of us, and so we must align ourselves with those we members. Do you hear politicians doing this in their speeches
他们利用承诺和一致性来游说他们的同事。他们利用团结原则来吸引潜在选民。这是人们常说的“我们对他们”的论点。如果另一方这么说，那么我们就不想这么做。如果我们的这一方采取了这个立场，那么它的优点是什么几乎就不重要了。它是我们自己人，所以我们必须与我们的那些成员保持一致。你听到政客们在他们的演讲中这样做吗？
and in their messaging? All the time. All the time isn't it the case that that's what we hear them doing. Don't be like the other people who are against us and not of us, be like us. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing And are you worried? Do you worry at all that these techniques, these ideas, which of course can be used for both good and evil might end up being used for evil rather than good? I do worry about it. I claim that the one way that we can insulate ourselves from this kind of unethical approach is to only use the principles that we can point to in the situation that are naturally, inherently there.
以及在他们的信息传递中？一直都在。一直都在，难道我们听到的不正是他们这样做吗？不要像那些反对我们、不是我们一伙的人那样，要像我们一样。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中] 而且你担心吗？你是否有一点担心，这些技术、这些理念——它们当然既可以用于行善，也可以用于作恶——最终可能会被用来作恶而不是行善？我的确为此感到担心。我声称，我们能够让自己免受这种不道德方法侵害的唯一途径，是只使用那些在现实情况中能够被指出是自然且固有存在的原则。
Is there true social proof you're allowed to point to it? Is there true scarcity? Yes, bring that to consciousness. Is there true authority that's aligned with the position? Yes, make that available to people. That is informing them into a scent. It's not tricking them or deceiving them, coercing them.
是否存在你可以指出的真实社会认同？是否存在真正的稀缺性？是的，把这一点唤醒。是否存在与该立场一致的真正权威？是的，让人们可以获得这一点。那是在用信息引导他们做出认同。而不是愚弄他们、欺骗他们或胁迫他们。
It's manipulative to fake the presence of one or another of these principles in a situation. Whenever we come across an instance of one of those corporations, one of those marketers, one of those advertisers, who is using one of the principles unethically, we have to call them out. We have to go online and let them know and the people, my patronize their products or services, what we have experienced and we penalize them for it. That's the way I would, I think, make a clear distinction. I'm wondering if there's a wrap-up idea that you want to leave
在一个情境中伪造其中一个或另一个原则的存在是具有操纵性的。每当我们遇到那些公司、那些营销人员、那些广告商中的某个实例，他们不道德地使用这些原则时，我们必须公开指责他们。我们必须上网让他们以及那些光顾他们的产品或服务的人知道我们的经历，并对他们进行惩罚。我认为，这就是我会做出明确区分的方式。我在想，你是否有一个总结性的观点想要留给
people with as they think about the world of influence and persuasion because of course, it's not as if we can live our lives without being influencers and persuaders. You know, even if we're not politicians or public figures, we're always influencing and persuading other people and always being influenced and persuaded by other people. How should we think about these ideas that you spend these many decades studying, Bob? Well, we first have to know what are the major influences on the influence process. And then I'm going to revert to what I was saying about the importance of employing them only by bringing attention to them where they naturally reside in the influence
人们去思考影响力和说服力的世界，因为当然，我们的生活不可能没有影响力制造者和说服者。你知道的，即使我们不是政客或公众人物，我们也在不断地影响和说服他人，并且不断地被他人所影响和说服。我们应该如何看待你花了几十年时间研究的这些理念呢，鲍勃？嗯，我们首先必须了解对影响力过程的主要影响因素是什么。然后我将回到我之前所说的关于只通过在影响力环境中自然存在的那些地方吸引注意力来运用它们的重要性
setting. If we do that, I don't know who loses under those circumstances. We're a better culture as a result. Robert Chaldeini is the author of Influence, the Psychology of Persuasion. Bob, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. I enjoyed it. We're thinking of trying something new today. Many listeners email us with thoughts and questions after episodes run. We're exploring the possibility of regular follow-up conversations
如果我们这样做，我不知道在那种情况下谁会是输家。结果是我们拥有更好的文化。罗伯特·查尔迪尼是《影响力：说服的心理学》一书的作者。鲍勃，谢谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。我很喜欢这次交谈。我们今天正考虑尝试一些新的东西。许多听众在节目播出后发电子邮件给我们分享他们的想法和问题。我们正在探讨进行定期后续对话的可能性
in which our listeners can pose their questions to our guests. If you have questions or thoughts about our series with Bob Chaldeini and are willing to have those questions shared with a larger Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasat HiddenBrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again, email the question to us at ideasathydenbrain.org and use the subject line, Persuasion episodes.
听众可以在其中向我们的嘉宾提出他们的问题。如果你对我们与鲍勃·查尔迪尼的系列节目有任何问题或想法，并且愿意与更广泛的《隐秘大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在你的手机上录制一条语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@HiddenBrain.org。60秒就足够了。请记得附上你的名字和一个可以联系到你的电话号码。再次强调，请将问题发送至我们的邮箱ideas@HiddenBrain.org，并使用主题行：说服力节目（Persuasion episodes）。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Unsung Hero this week comes from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. In the summer of 2008, Rick Magnol was making the long commute from his home in the remote mountains of three rivers, California, to his job at a community college in the town of Viselia. At the time, he was living in a travel trailer, which was often invaded by the
《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄来自我们的姐妹播客《我的无名英雄》。2008年夏天，里克·马格诺尔长途跋涉，从他位于加利福尼亚州三河市偏远山区家出发，前往他位于维塞利亚镇一所社区大学的工作地点。当时，他住在旅行拖车里，而该拖车经常受到该地区
abundant wildlife in the area. He would find bats in his curtains, rattlesnakes under his trailer, and bears at his window. But the one that is most problematic for me, the scorpions, and they get into everything. They get into cabinets somehow, they get into a drawer with your clothes. And the only way to stop it is to smash them. That particular day, I got up, put my clothes on, got in the car, and started driving. The drive took him down a road that was flanked on both sides by large slabs of granite rock. All of a sudden, a scorpion that had somehow gotten into his clothes crawled out and stung him on the back. When he tried to smash it, he accidentally yanked the steering wheel down and to the right.
丰富的野生动物的侵扰。他会在窗帘里发现蝙蝠，在拖车底下发现响尾蛇，在窗户旁发现熊。但对我来说最麻烦的是蝎子，它们无孔不入。它们不知怎么能钻进橱柜里，还能钻进装衣服的抽屉里。唯一的阻止办法就是把它们砸死。那天我起床，穿好衣服，坐进车里，开始开车。车子开过的一条路两边都是大块的花岗岩巨石。突然，一只不知怎么钻进他衣服里的蝎子爬了出来，蛰了他的背。当他试图砸死它时，他不小心把方向盘猛地向下拉并向右偏。
And when I looked up, I was looking right at a sheer granite embankment. And I hit that rock wall and I still recall the sensation of my on-decivic going airborne. And I can feel it now, feeling the car flip in the air, just feeling being upside down in my seatbelt. And about that time, an old white Ford pickup going the other direction pulled over across the road from me.
当我抬起头时，我看到眼前的正是一面陡峭的花岗岩路堤。我撞上了那堵岩石墙，我至今仍记得我的思域汽车腾空而起的感触。我现在还能感觉到，感觉到车子在空中翻滚，感觉到系着安全带倒挂在座椅上的感觉。就在这时，一辆迎面开来的旧白色福特皮卡车在路的另一边靠边停下了。
And two Hispanic guys jumped out and one of them directed the other one to go up around the corner of the road to slow traffic down and directed around me because I was in the middle of the lane. And the other one came across the street. I don't remember what he said or what I said, but he didn't speak more and a couple words of English. And he put his hand on my shoulder. And I tried to tell him he could go. Rick worried that the two men were undocumented. So I thought he probably should get out of there because I'd called 911 and highway patrol would be coming and could get a question or picked up. I had no idea what would happen. So, I tried to reassure him that I was okay, but he would have none of it.
两名西班牙裔男子跳了出来，其中一人指挥另一人去路的拐角处减缓交通速度，并指挥车辆绕过我，因为我正停在车道中间。另一个人横穿马路。我不记得他说了什么，也不记得我说了什么，但他只会说一两个英文单词。他把手放在我的肩膀上。我试图告诉他他可以走了。
He just stood with me. And he stood there with me for maybe 20 minutes, maybe. We didn't have any conversation, but when the highway patrol showed up, I looked up and this fellow was gone. The truck was gone. they just melted away. I wish I had thanked you. I wish I had thanked you. Rick Magnum of Dexter Oregon. To share a story about your unsung hero, record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at myunsungheroatHiddenBrain.org.
他只是和我站在一起。他可能跟我站了20分钟左右。我们没有进行任何交谈，但当高速公路巡警出现时，我抬起头，这个人已经不见了。卡车也不见了。他们就这样消失得无影无踪。我真希望当时能对你说一声谢谢。我真希望当时能对你说一声谢谢。俄勒冈州德克斯特的里克·马格诺尔。要分享关于你的无名英雄的故事，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至myunsunghero@HiddenBrain.org。
Again, that email address is myunsungheroatHiddenBrain.org. If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. www.sususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususususus you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次强调，电子邮件地址是myunsunghero@HiddenBrain.org。如果你喜欢这期节目，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有帮助，请尽自己的一份力帮助我们成长。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦当塔姆。我们很快再见。这里还没有关于这期节目的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。